I can report through the government's  monitoring and testing program that as  of today 6600 and 12,000 and 31 tests  for coronavirus have now been carried  out in the UK including 28,000 532 tests  yesterday 143 thousand 464 people have  tested positive that's an increase of  five thousand three hundred and eighty  six cases since yesterday 17,000 of 49  people are currently in hospital with  corona virus in the UK that's down from  17 thousand six hundred and fifteen the  day before and down 10 percent on the  same day last week and sadly of those in  hospital with the virus 19 thousand 506  have now had died that's an increase of  684 fatalities since yesterday we  expressed our condolences to their  families their friends we must not  forget that each of these statistics  represents a personal tragedy